alright I'm gonna help you out here
we're gonna do the flip so all the way
under I don't know if I should help you
so I love fast food particularly Taco
Bell and I wanted to see if I could
recreate my favorite item the Crunchwrap
supreme right here I heard that you make
these on occasion once or twice
do you like Crunchwrap supreme as much
as I do
who doesn't I mean so good right a very
different aspect about this is we're
actually gonna be making a more
health-conscious
version we have Greek yogurt instead of
sour cream we have avocado oil instead
of your other oils you might use ground
turkey we said ground turkey we're gonna
go for a little spin on a classic and
hopefully it will hold its own against
the original are you feeling confident I
am I am I'm here to win I think it's
good to start with the meat we could
have gotten in taco seasoning but I said
no I said let's do some scratch we have
paprika cumin pepper salt oregano
cayenne and chili powder
I doubt talk about it has this many
seasonings in there I don't really cook
that often what's your cooking level
experience I cook at home I'm no fancy
chef okay
just a home close to home cook I start
with oil and most low oil here I can
move the cheese this is also some pepper
jack cheese we're not gonna be going
with the traditional nacho cheese that
Taco Bell uses so it's scooping avocado
I'm more of a peeler
oh oh really you know guess smart that
keeps it all together
oh yeah starting slow on the turkey I
might as well just wing some of these
spices yeah this is the fun part I'm
just gonna go for it
that was some Cayenne okay no we're not
afraid of the spice this would be some
chili pepper paprika I guess I really
never thought about what goes into taco
seasoning we pepper cumin
oregano are we feeling about that do we
want it it's a strong nerdy heavy
seasoning yeah so this is looking good
it's not cooked yet but it's mixing yeah
what are you even doing what are you
guys are you guys seeing this right now
ready I think you're more than just a
home cook and it's dice what I you know
I always use sour cream but okay Greek
yogurt you make a little sandwich out of
these tostada shells yeah which adds
that whole layer of crunch well I looked
up a bunch of recipes for it and a lot
of people say that you really can't
taste the difference between Greek
yogurt and sour cream
amazing I don't know I've never tested
that back I didn't know for a fact there
is an avocado on that's half of oh oh no
way that's not good that's been animated
another delicate part of creating these
Crunchwrap Supremes would be like you
can't overload them you can't put too
much in can then you really have an
issue at the top so we're gonna do a
practical example of what you can make
at home
oh I think I was supposed to add the
onions into this 7 to 8 if they're a
little crunchy that's okay it just adds
of the crunch from that kind of
different these are yellow pre-cut from
the store I didn't want to cry on camera
we got also some pre shredded iceberg
lettuce did not want to do that either
I'm just trying to cook okay how are
those onions are they soft they're
they're softening yeah we could probably
make some with turkey friends mix them
together yeah make it a party I think is
almost ready oh wow that's beautiful
we did it okay it's assembly time okay
it says I'm laid up and now we need
another pan
next step we're gonna warm up the
tortilla yay this is this might take a
while
but we have to be patient as I learned
is keen cooking
we definitely have all the necessary
components okay I think it's time cheese
cheese ultimate melt eNOS let's do
double meat double cheese so we'll do
okay now let's put one of those things
on Wow do with this bowl it's gonna be
hard we could also break it we could
cheese oh my god
for me I'm scared Harvey Anna folds is
ideally a bigger tortilla would have
been nice well add some tomatoes some
avocados this is beautiful so far the
inside
lettuce also serves as a really good
barrier for like Wayne this will not end
up folding correctly I see we're gonna
have to really crunch this down we got
it look at this you just do like Wow any
turn wow this is the thickest thick
crunch wrap I've ever seen okay this
corner first okay should we what do we
do
do we push it down evening yeah how did
you hear that yeah it's not my best work
but I mean it looks good wait did we
forget this I know that's inside of here
oh I mean oh I mean oh wow
just pam pam okay so you can it up
Oh God wasn't the best it's okay just
commit this is a meal I don't know if I
should help you
oh it's okay we'll do another one that's
less in the inside but we can put it
here for now and start on our yeah okay
it's the first pancake you can see that
we didn't get it fold it in completely
we were starting strong we need to put
less in the inside try number 2 for the
second one this is a little big to fold
around so we're gonna try breaking it up
and see if we get a better fold okay
let's try it again
cheese meat crunchies tomatoes avocado
still tall it's it's so good hungry okay
I think we got this okay this is like
watching a master at work moment of
truth
oh it's looking really good I have a bit
more control got a bit of a rip it it's
okay
so who had Taco Bell is doing these
folds that's what I want to know I'm
another factory they have to that's
looking that's great we abandon our
avocado and a healthy swap was temporary
no oh no pop the baby okay we got it we
gotta be on it
you did it this has been a journey knots
and downs the effort involved in this is
not a lot this was pretty easy to do
it's like your standard dinner folding
is really the key okay I think it's time
you guys do it okay what I mean I'm sure
it's gonna taste great it's not it
positive ill taste fantastic
[Music]
all right the moment is here we're going
to taste our Crunchwrap Supremes
obviously there's a big difference in
looks I think they had a much bigger
tortilla this we did our best as what I
could find at the market yeah
try to true ratios I feel like really I
probably flip this up a bit so we're
going to be judging our Crunchwrap
supreme on the time it took to make it
look cost the taste and the presentation
so right off the bat I think ours loses
some points to the presentation but
that's okay good mean I don't look over
time the time wasn't too bad it's your
average meal probably like 30 minutes 30
minutes or so Kosta means it's not as
cheap as a Crunchwrap supreme that you
can definitely make more with the
ingredients that we've got so let's go
through the taste
so let's first taste our our talk about
which we know that we like mm-hmm so
they're layering those beef and cheese
crunchy taco then it looks like sour
cream onions and lettuce tomato
definitely I know why I love me they're
really good let's see if ours can even
hold a candle to the original Crunchwrap
supreme let's go for it
mm-hmm
it does have some of the same flavors I
do feel like we kind of somehow found
that like secret taco bell like meat
it's weird yeah this is definitely the
like healthier homemade version I'm
pleasantly surprised by ours our boudin
coming down just based on taste based on
taste look I gotta give it to the
original us you're gonna give it to
cocky well good I'm gonna have to give
you the Taco Bell - it was so good I
mean we really tried our best
the thing about Taco Bell is you go to
Taco Bell for that signature Taco Bell
taste and that's something I don't know
if you can really replicate on your own
I definitely want to make this again and
we'll eat this again like this this is
really really good even though we both
picked the Taco Bell option it was a
really really hard choice I can see
myself making this versus going to Taco
Bell even though I love the original
Crunchwrap supreme and it is a healthier
option and if that's what you're going
for then this is a
good option it's fun to experiment it's
fun to try to mix of that home do you
guys have any recipe swaps that you make
any healthy swaps for fast food please
leave them in the comments below you
might as well try
[Music]
you